en colonia en el oeste de alemania el
tema está en medio de todas las
conversaciones las economías de energía
pedidas por el gobierno federal en este
edificio el agua caliente ha sido
cortada de un día para otro esta mujer
está preocupada por su madre de 86 años
y necesita agua caliente especialmente
durante el invierno es muy anciana los
habitantes de esta residencia no quieren
de estas impuestas medidas de ahorro
cuando nuestro gobierno se hizo
demasiado dependiente de otros países y
ahora somos nosotros quienes pagamos el
precio
economías para los particulares pero
también para las comunas en berlín la
municipalidad decidió dejar de alumbrar
varios monumentos durante la noche como
la columna de la victoria o el castillo
de charlottenburg pero según este
economista se deben encontrar soluciones
a largo plazo y hay que invertir en las
energías alternativas los próximos dos o
tres años serán críticos pero si hacemos
las cosas bien y si hacemos más para
ahorrar el gas la energía y desarrollar
más las energías renovables entonces
podremos encontrar una salida y superar
la crisis
soluciones que se hacen urgentes ya que
el país depende en gran medida del gas
ruso antes de la guerra representaba el
55 por ciento de sus importaciones